Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
A few years ago, Dan, I learned
about something called popcorning.
Yeah, I mean, we did a
video with popcorn before,
you know popping the
kernels and everything.
This is slightly different,
Slightly different.
It's when a person, sometimes
unknowingly, sits on an airbag
and it goes off, and launches
them, probably halfway
to the moon sometimes.
I mean, usually I'm a fan
of like, pranks and things,
and I'm usually up for anything,
but I definitely, I'm not up for this.
Well we've got an airbag
and because you didn't
want to do it, we sort
of hired a new member
of the team, didn't we?
Yeah, we did.
So this is to save my back.
Oh god .
Oh bless his legs, watch out, oh god.
His bloody legs are spread.
All right, this is,
we've named him Slow Moe.
Yeah.
M-O-E, Moe.
Now he is up for anything.
Yeah, just in case, you
know, we weren't already
enough, like, "MythBusters,"
although this is cheaper
than Buster, I think.
Yeah, that's fair.
Yeah.
Definitely.
So shall we wire up
an air bag and see how he does?
So I've perched him on this airbag here.
Careful.
Obviously.
Careful where you're reaching.
Oh, sorry, pal.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
And it's all hooked up, I
just need to connect these two
to a car battery, and we'll
be good to go on the airbag.
I hope he survives,
Yeah.
this honestly, slightly nervous for him,
but I've tilted him sort of
like a nice jaunty angle,
and yeah, hopefully he doesn't
smash anything on his way up.
Well, he doesn't look scared.
He doesn't, no you're right.
In order to not have
Moe crush the Phantom,
we've put the Phantom
under this handy table.
This might be the first
and last appearance of Moe.
What are your predictions?
I think he's gonna have a really bad time.
I think he's gonna shed
limbs and head, maybe.
Hopefully we'll see why
I didn't want to do this
Yeah.
and we've got a mannequin.
I think we'll learn that
within the first 0.1 second of detonation
Right, we're connected to negative.
Three, two, one.
It sounded like a head rolling there.
You couldn't pose it better,
as in like, he looks
like he's been blown up.
He does.
Doesn't he?
He like, like his arm's
off, no his hand is off.
Little smolder.
His head's off.
So do you think he just went up
and then face planted back down?
I think he, I think we made him popcorn.
I wonder how high he went.
I wonder if he just went, like.
That looks uncomfortable.
It looks painful, but I
didn't fling him that far.
I mean, just sort of like,
he just left the ground.
I'll be honest, by the way it sounded,
I thought it was gonna be
a lot higher than that.
That was very lackluster.
Oh, his face.
That's a scar on the forehead.
For sure.
I thought he'd like hit
the shelves or something,
the amount of noise that was.
I mean, even still,
that's really cool to see
how quick the air bag was out isn't it?
All right, he didn't
seem to go far, did he?
No, he didn't, so.
Try the different bag.
Yeah, try a different bag,
and I'm gonna just try putting
it upside down this time,
so that the airbag part of it points down,
rather than up into him.
You ready?
Yep.
Three, two, one.
Oh, it broke his legs.
Oh god.
What has gone on there?
Where's the air bag gone?
Oh.
I need to move it.
How did it go over there?
Did it melt my camera charger?
I don't think it did.
Well, his ass is cracked, so let's see
if we can see how it happened.
Oh.
Okay.
I think that putting the air bag downwards
actually puts more pressure into,
like it wastes the energy
on the airbag flinging up.
And I think because his
legs are off frontwards,
the way the angle of the airbag comes out,
just propels it backwards,
smashing it right into all
of our charging equipment.
But like, it was like,
it was almost like the airbag bag went
just the most expensive direction like in,
ah, ah, that one.
All right, so this isn't working as it is
in the videos we've seen,
and I think the common thread
in all the videos we've
watched is that the airbag
is always contained,
in a chair, in a tire,
something that stops the
airbag from wasting energy
outwards, and just forcing
all of it straight up.
We're gonna give him
a bad time, aren't we?
Yeah.
So I think I'm gonna go to
the scrap yard and get a tire
with which to contain the airbag,
and also maybe some bigger air bags.
Cause these ones are...
The passenger one.
Yeah, these ones are steering wheel one,
I'm gonna get the passenger one.
All right, it's a new dawn.
♪ It's a new day ♪
Yeah, it's a new copyright strike.
Is that a copyright strike?
No, so we've got him on a tire now.
Hopefully that'll prevent
any sort of side spreadage
of the airbag, wasted energy.
The one that propelled
the air bag over there.
Hopefully that won't happen.
It will just send all of the energy up.
Into Moe here.
Into Moe, yeah.
We've also changed the air bag.
We've gone for, instead
of a steering wheel one,
one of the passenger side ones,
which are potentially bigger,
because their airbag has to
reach a further distance.
Obviously, 'cause the steering
is right in front of you,
but then the passenger dash
is actually quite far away,
so usually bigger airbags.
Yeah, usually just more material.
Yeah.
do you think the lenses are safe?
You don't think it will
chuck something at the glass?
I don't think it will.
Okay.
Ready?
Yep.
Three, two, one.
Oh my god.
It ripped his arm off.
His arm's off.
Oh, he went...
Okay, I'll be honest, I'll be honest.
Something made a difference there.
I'll be honest.
In there, I was trying
to wait four seconds,
but the noise, the noise never stopped.
It was like ,
so I don't know when to trigger.
Do you know that bit
on "Lord of the Rings,"
when they're in Moria, and
I think it's Peregrine Took
knocks that bucket over into the well,
and it's like, .
And it's just a close up of his face.
It's like.
Yeah.
That's what we were like in there.
I feel like a cave troll's about to bust
through the garage door, any second.
Look at this.
Oh my god, is that still
gonna work or is it just
completely jacked.
No, that's busted.
Oh no.
We've got bits of hand and finger,
I assume, down here.
I think he's done for.
He is done for.
He's got a leg off.
No, he's got an entire leg off,
which has gone over there
and smashed your batteries.
Yeah, we lost a battery charger.
His hand landed on the lens case,
well the hand that didn't explode.
He's got a leg over here.
Did he go that far?
Flipping heck.
He's gone every direction.
That's not bounce damage.
Is that explosion damage?
I think he blew up.
You kidding?
That, honestly, I didn't have high hopes
for the video after the
first couple of attempts.
Disappointing.
Lackluster.
Yeah, lackluster is the word.
That one...
Is that, is that his head?
Oh.
I looked at it and I saw it,
'cause it wasn't there.
Is that like a piece of him
that's brushed against the ceiling?
I think he's, I think he's done it.
I think he's hit the ceiling, you know?
Oh, his hand is here.
Oh man, like there's fingers everywhere,
and I didn't know where
the rest of the hand was,
and this is it.
It's like he lost his thumb, his index,
and his the middle tip.
Yeah.
I mean you get to see what did the damage,
was it him landing or the explosion?
Oh, it just blew his knees out.
He just blew up.
His hand.
Oh, it's gonna like smash something.
Oh, oh my god.
Jesus.
We just blew him apart.
Not only that, the airbag
also flew in there.
It just, yeah, it went straight up.
It was exactly how the tire
was supposed to work in it.
He's not even in the frame anymore.
To be honest, I zoomed in a little bit
because the other ones were too wide.
Oh no.
The whole thing came down
in the charging area.
Okay, see look, okay,
there's a lot going on here.
The hand didn't smash on the floor,
the hand smashed on the ceiling, I think.
'Cause he's already lost
his thumb and finger.
Yeah, yeah, and there's
bits of hand everywhere.
The whole of Moe landed
on the charging area.
Oh, he's just thumped
himself on the table there.
That came..
That came close to that lens.
Wait, 'cause the other
camera was here as well.
Yeah.
So, I guess it must've
just like missed, just.
I'll be honest, I think the hand
went between the two cameras.
.
That was, that could have been
really bad.
That was irresponsible.
We thought we'd be safe
with this table here.
Do you think the lenses are safe?
You don't think it will
chuck something at the glass?
I don't think it will.
Holy crap, that was a difference.
He turned into a bomb.
That was mental.
Oh my god, he hit the ceiling.
He did.
I think his head.
I think...
So, what bit hit the light?
You can see him bouncing off the ceiling,
even though it's out of
frame, you can see it.
It stops him.
I can't believe it didn't do more damage.
There is no way you could
be in the room with this.
You would have been, it
turned him into shrapnel.
It did, it was dangerous.
That could have been so bad.
It would have been, you know,
an insurance claim, but still.
That's not what you want, really.
That's not what you want.
So what happened, sir?
Okay, well the bloke's hand flew off.
We didn't do this one outside
because it's not good weather today.
It's dark, it's wet,
but I think we actually
got a lot out of doing it
in a compressed space.
Like we got stuff that
wouldn't have happened outside.
Well, we'd have lost the hand, for sure.
The hand would've been gone.
That would have been in
the neighbor's backyard.
Yeah, yeah there's, probably a leg
would have disappeared as well.
All right, let's not do anymore.
Oh, there's a smudge, look.
He's left a little smudge on the wall.
Oh god.
Yeah, that's him isn't it.
Yeah, so it looks like
we've lost that arm.
This arm's gone.
Both of these legs have
been, like stripped.
The thing is, is that this,
this is what holds the lower leg in place
and that's ripped open, which
means the whole leg is gone.
Whereas, you know,
actually we can probably
use the top half again, except it...
Smashed his gooch.
Yeah, the gooch, gooch?
The gooch.
Le gooch.
It's made a rubber smush.
Is that from where the wheel was sat?
Yeah, so this is where the wheel was,
and the force of the airbag
pushing down into the ground
has caused the...
Look, you can even read it.
The like, the rubber.
That says SSP93?
Oh, oh it's backwards, 'cause
obviously they're smushed.
It's smushed.
It's obviously just mirrored.
So are you glad that it
wasn't you in Moe's place?
Are you, do you mean, am I glad
that my leg hasn't come off?
I need a new gooch.
I've ripped mine off.
Can you imagine
if I'd walked in after you were on it,
and you were the exact same damage.
You walked over to your battery like,
"Oh no, my battery."
Ah, well maybe we can
work on repairing him
and using him in a future video,
but we'll put him in, we'll put
him in temporary retirement.
So don't try that with
a mannequin or a human.
Oops.
Stop breaking it.
Make sure...
I'm so gutted that he
didn't last one episode.
Make sure you subscribe to Slo
Mo Guys, my second channel,
we're on social media, and in
memory of old Slow Moe 1.0,
give that bell a little ring
Yeah, honor.
in his honor.
Tribute.
I'm gonna go and paint
that dent in the wall.
I'm gonna get some super
glue and try and fix him.